what is a bubble it's hollow inside full
of hot air and it gets bigger and bigger
until it bursts in recent years we've
seen speculative bubbles housing bubbles
the dot-com bubble they happen when
prices inflate far beyond the value of
the product just like during the 1637
and xiulet main here in Holland the
newly introduced flowers were so popular
that their prices rose to astronomical
Heights merchants bought huge numbers of
bulbs expecting to make huge profits
driving the prices up still further
three bulbs reportedly sold for the
price of a house but suddenly doubt
crept into the equation were price and
supply properly balanced dealers
panicked and flooded the market prices
collapsed slowly at first but then
faster and faster falling to levels far
below what the dealers have paid the
losses ruined many of them the bubble
had burst but the lesson was not learned
there have been many more bubbles since
then in commodities and internet
companies stocks in real estate like in
the u.s. when banks gave loans for house
purchases without security
that was okay as long as prices
continued to rise but then they fell the
houses lost value as did the loans the
housing bubble burst banks went broke
and that set off a worldwide financial
crisis simple arithmetic won't help
predict bubbles psychologists say human
greed plays a role as does the herd
instinct
we may only notice bubbles once they pop
but some see a positive side when they
finally burst afterwards the only assets
usually left are those that are worth
something